the Joe Rogan experience well this
article in the Atlantic was really
disturbing where they were saying that
if the people that are going in to find
out if they have kovat they can't even
give them this was in New York they
couldn't even give them a test because
they didn't meet a certain criteria and
if they didn't have it before they
definitely have it now there's other
people in this waiting room yeah and
they're all waiting and they're all sick
and coughing like [ __ ] christ so
what's the point at which you're
supposed to go in because just get it
yeah I mean what do you mean know what I
mean what's the point where you should
go to the doctor versus sit it out and
try to because they say 90% of the
people that come in
have pneumonia or the flu they don't
have kovat well that's the thing is that
the flu still here right so it's
happening at the same time as the flu
but it's a new thing obviously we know
what to do with the flu you could put
give people Tamiflu you know you can get
a flu shot you much like we had dr.
Hotez explain how even if you get a flu
shot from the wrong kind of flu to make
a vaccine it still has enough of the the
things in it that fight off parts of the
flu cos of flu is a virus has a bunch of
different components and so it can
mitigate some of the components even if
it's not the perfect vaccine for that
virus so it still protects you somewhat
protects you better than not having
anything so that's the flu like there's
a bunch of [ __ ] with this thing they're
like we don't we don't know yeah you
know we don't we really don't know we
don't know what's going on I mean people
talk about all these different
treatments that may or may not be
effective but this is too new for the
most part you really just need a
ventilator I mean that's the only thing
you would need medical care for right
cuz I can't do much for you otherwise
well there's been some talk about Z
packs you know but there's no there's no
definitive evidence and those when they
run studies like that takes a long-ass
time to get you know if they're doing
double-blind placebo-controlled studies
you're trying to find out what what does
what and what's effective for what and
any kind of clinical trial I think takes
months right oh no a year it's a year is
it yeah because they think they've
already identified some vaccines but
they said for it to
you know if you don't test it you could
put it out and kill as many people with
the vaccine yeah yeah yeah yeah and at
the same time Tiger King becomes the
number one show in the world
the same time a documentary on wild
tigers they're in captivity at this
crazy dudes place who's married to two
other crazy dudes who's in a battle with
this lady who might have fed her
ex-husband two tigers right don't tell
me I haven't seen a spoiler yeah what do
you think Jamie about the whole about
did that lady feed her husband to the
tiger if I if you had a million dollars
today reopen the case did it yesterday
yeah they're looking back into it
they're looking into maybe I don't know
bro if you have a husband that's a
millionaire and you raise Tigers and
then that guy disappears and no one
knows where he is if that happens I
think people should be suspicious
they'll be like okay where is he you
don't know where he is at all huh he
just went away huh how many Tigers you
have you have a hundred Tigers can we
see your Tigers tranq your Tigers and
examine their [ __ ] and survive through
lab like this human [ __ ] here
this is human and you ain't a human this
tiger ate a human oh my god this lady
fed our [ __ ] husband to Tigers well
she needs a meat grinder she must have a
meat grinder so she needs she throws the
husband in the meat grinder throws the
piles out there where the Tigers eat and
they just tear him apart like Scarface
97 dude I think that was a real thing
with drug dealers was getting a tiger
for that reason oh well that's always
been the thing with people with pigs
that was in that movie snatch oh that's
right that's right greedy pigs yeah guy
with the crazy glasses
[Applause]